makes me want to look at different like
each conversation I have I'm like home
what is this where's the where's the poo
oh it's coming oh your prayers never say
where's the food no no today we're going
to be playing two truths and a lie
we're gonna have three people come in
two people are telling the truth and one
person is lying a good way to tell
someone's lying is sometimes I feel like
when people over explain what's gonna
come down here is the questions the
follow-up questions and how they answer
those put on my interrogation face okay
I am a distant relative of Scott
Thompson who is better known as carrot
top I once got a pedicure with Bill
Murray I've done full drag as pit bull
Charles Charles Charles how did you find
this out so my mom's second cousin is
Donna
his mom and whenever whenever her
husband got a job working you know for
NASA they had to move down to Cape
Canaveral so that's that's where they
were so care tops mom Donna her husband
works at NASA Larry Larry used to her I
mean he's Larry and Donna Larry and
Donna working at NASA okay have you so
have you ever met your cousin I I have
met him before I got to meet him in
Vegas we'd never really like connected
when he cuz I mean he was famous before
I was born
how did he react when he met out he was
so nice he's honestly like it's yeah and
it I mean it's the best soul I've
experienced ever have so is your hair
red I can't tell this lighting it's not
what questionable when I grow out my
beard it's wrong oh but she just
happened to shave your beard before
today yes feel like how he's delivering
things I can't tell if it's very like
rehearsed or if it's natural because
he's changing up the
need of what he says huh it's very
thought out maybe maybe in the car you
checked so it never came up when you
were younger that he was your cousin my
mom only brought it up when we were
watching some show and she was like you
know you're you know you're related to
that guy how did you guys meet in the
first place like you don't just run up
on carrot top and be like I'm your
cousin I'm mom talked to his mom and I
was like can I could I get tickets to
the show and then on day of like I
basically talked through his like people
or handlers or stuff like that and like
I got to meet him I used I don't know
well I feel like everything's gonna be
all right
I once got a pedicure with Bill Murray
oh yes where this is in New York why
together or you got a pedicure and he
was there he was there i sat next to him
would you go back bro or my friends at
next time and I sat on the other side
okay I didn't talk to him cuz like now
he's like goes to people's weddings and
stuff but at the time he was still known
to be pretty standoffish and I have like
a long history of like really making a
half of myself in front of celebrities
so I like didn't want to sing and he
thinks so I was like very silent but my
friend chatted with him and he was very
nice
what does he look yeah what did his feel
what they did it look it look like he
was something exposed but I was so
nervous and I will say this he seemed to
be a regular at this place was it this
year let no this was a while ago this
was almost I would say almost 10 years
ago was he nice to the nail techs yes he
was very polite and then he got a he got
a yeah what did he get a mani pedi
no he got a massage afterwards
I don't think it was that kind o those
my ex question what is Becky short for
we're back in the car you Rebecca so
your friend said next to you what's your
friend's name
my friend's name is Lisa I've done full
drag as pit bull okay okay when did you
start doing drag uh I don't do it
regularly it's something I'm working
towards actually because I'm a clown
your comment I realize like it's not
like red nose combo like I do like some
slight clowning Wow like okay wait
clowning like I make jokes my friends
are like literally you mean like like I
I yeah I want to study like French
clowns
wow that's very interesting why pit bull
why not I love pit bull so is this a wig
that you are currently wearing people
blog no it's attached okay how did you
go ball did you shave your head when you
didn't know I still want to know like
why not isn't a good enough reason for
me I went to school in Miami School
University Miami okay so he's like my
height man of her life yeah have you
ever met people
no my biggest regret is not going on the
pit bull cruise I don't know I'm
figuring out my drag persona a little
bit would you wear
I had on black pants a black button down
in a bow tie and then like a blue I
guess sports coat and then I did a chain
you know right and like the big aviators
who went with you when you did drag um
it was for like a comedy show so like my
improv team was all there and what are
the members of your groups names do you
want all we've got Silvano we've got
Gavi we have Michelle Rochelle and who
else is Darby Chelsea and then there's
me see it's here right gonna cause here
I'm gonna I'm gonna a joke oh I mean I
know oh we know I don't know if I should
tell you because I don't I want to win
wow that's an interesting perspective
there yeah I definitely don't think it's
these two you think it's Rebecca yeah
she had to think about things
yeah she really had to guess her
friend's name yeah got me off a little
bit in a no offense it was ten years ago
she knows her friend Chuck in the NASA
stories yeah yeah the thing that feels
weird to me is just like hitting up the
app yeah and just being like hey can I
go that's weird
no no people do yes and then Sarah I
believe it I don't know oh yeah it just
seems about right yeah yeah no one's
blinking and it's really freaking me out
maybe no wait a minute is that an option
can nobody be a liar is that option all
right
my vote is I think it's Becky that's
lying I think I'm gonna go with that I
think Chuck's line okay okay I'm gonna
go with Becky as well
[Music]
on the trees oh yeah
I was telling the truth I was telling a
lie everything all yeah is any of it did
you go to kick up show is your name
Charles my name is Charles oh I've never
been a carrot top I've never seen a show
do you have a ginger beard was he not
true no wow see Larry and Donna are
those his actual pairs those are his
parents
his name is Scott sausage why do you oh
you look that up yeah it's on this
Wikipedia page